my name is Sumit I'm a senior machine
learning engineer I hail from Dallas
Texas I've been working in the computer
vision space for the last six and a half
years first I worked in the healthcare
space and now I work primarily in the
retail space
uh so I started working with deep
learning back in 2016
started using tensorflow like when it
was just too new
so as a developer what we generally do
is whenever we have issues we try to
debug and understand what's going on I
am not the kind of a guy who use like
console print statements to debug but
use
um
programming tool like pycharm put
breakpoints and try to go like step by
step and understand what's going on
where there's an issue right can we do
something similar to deep neural
networks that's where I started working
towards and trying to see that can we
not see this as a black box and is there
a better way to do it of course
scientists like Jeff Hinton Jan likon
these guys they clearly know what's
happening in each individual Network
when they came up with techniques like
Dropout they they're like okay there's
something like bagging I think to get at
that Granite level you gotta like Master
it but are there other ways to also do
it so this is when my journey towards
moral interpretability for CV model
started so today I would like to talk a
little bit about how we can interpret
deep learning models and how we can get
insights from it
how many of you are familiar with deep
learning here
okay okay uh those who are not uh what
is deep learning is it for specifically
for computer vision ability for machines
to automatically learn to extract
meaningful features from raw image data
okay to get into the more detail part of
it meaningful features meaning what is
unique about an image right say if you
take an image of a dog you know that the
the way the dog's eyes ears nose is it's
completely different to any other animal
in the world kind of that's how humans
see it and we are trying to see whether
machine can do the same and generalize
it right so this is what is deep
learning but also the other thing is
prior to deep learning you had like
traditional image processing techniques
take for example Kenny Edge filter it's
a very simple Edge detection filter
there is a simple algorithm that you run
and then it just gives you the edges
right but in deep learning you are not
putting any algorithms there but you are
making the machine learn these by just
feeding tons and tons of data so this is
what is basically features for a single
image right
now what is model interpretability
let us take a simple example ah a simple
neural network called convolutional
neural network
ah the Assumption here is the neural
network is already trained on few
animals in that zebra is one of them in
as seen here and then at test time or
inference time you give an image of a
zebra that was not given in the training
and then you feed it through the neural
network and it gives you a confidence
like it gave you a confidence of 0.7
right
how do you interpret this like okay you
got a points and accuracy but what is it
that the machine actually learned like
how could it say it right so this is
basically model interpretability how do
you interpret your results so I'll be
talking more about that
and the next thing is why Model
interpretability A it is explaining to
business and stakeholders and B it is to
debug your neural network right so when
I say explain to business stakeholder
lot of Business Leaders they don't know
what a neural network is and they don't
want to know as well right but when you
but when when you uh build something uh
like a simple stop sign detector which
solves a huge problem to one of the CFOs
right when you go to him he'll be like
hey what are you doing like can you tell
me more about this I can't believe this
right how do you make sure these
Business Leaders understand in a very
simple way and not get into the
technical details right visualization is
too powerful so can you basically
visualize it and say that hey I think
this is the reason why I'm getting this
result and this is why I feel uh it
works and I think this is the reason why
you should probably invest more or give
more attention to something like this
so how do you make it easy for them and
second is debugging neural networks like
how I started about development by using
breakpoints can you do something similar
on neural networks
so this is one of the example how do you
explain CV to business I took a very
simple example of a cup and the cup is
being already trained on and now a
business leader can clearly understand
what's really happening if you just tell
him that hey this is a neural network a
resonate backbone a vgg which has like
150 layers he'll not understand he'll
just not understand why do you how do
you actually break it down so that he
understands
this is one of the where where you can
directly tell that hey look the initial
layers it's actually learning the outer
side then when you go deeper down it's
learning the edges then when you go more
deeper it's trying to learn the
individual features of a cup which is
completely distinct from any other and
then this is how I'm finally giving the
answer right so this way if you can
clearly showcase the value that a deep
learning project can bring bring to the
table to business that's where I think
you have more success and more attention
to the project that you work on
second thing is debugging neural network
how many of you have actually trained a
deep neural network
okay okay
so when you train a neural network
the happy path is basically your loss
function has to reduce right
if your loss function does not reduce
then that's one of the indication that
the neural network is not learning
for those who don't know what's really
happening here is you are trying to
evaluate how well the model is learning
on the data that you provide and that
inference time when the model is already
trained on how the performance is like
in this case clearly it's overfitting
and there are situations wherein on a
happy path the train and the validation
they kind of go together this is when
the neural network is learning really
well
but this is not the only way uh offload
what's happening is with the crazy
progress in deep neural networks and the
research that's going on any of the
Shelf model you take and when you run
your custom data definitely your custom
data is not that big it'll always
converge so this term is basically
called converging it will always
converge but can you go deeper so
I can share one example that I actually
faced at work
so we were actually training um somewhat
like a One-Shot based neural network
when we were actually training a
One-Shot based neural network the loss
function started going into like
negative right when it started going
into negative like it started with
positive start going towards negative
and then there's a small error that had
to fix that's how I got to know and then
the loss function started like it didn't
go to like zero but it was like
0.008
0.00834835 it was like not going towards
zero but it was like so low but the
performance at inference was really bad
okay how do we figure out what's really
happening right apart from this one
signal of just noticing from the
training and variation logs
uh so certain ways I figured it out and
I would like to share that today apart
from the general train and validation
loss that you go through
ways of debugging neural networks there
are newer techniques Under the Umbrella
called explainable AI Frameworks it's
called xai you can find a lot of tools
there
there are some visualization tools that
you can use and there is some heuristic
based understanding that you can do
any one of you know about any of the
three
okay
like can you tell what you know
if possible
got it got it okay okay sounds good
got it got it so uh
for those who don't know visualization
tools these are basically tell you how
your data is going to be in like two
Dimension because you cannot go beyond
two Dimension it's really hard maybe
three but not beyond that but how to
make sure that a human himself can
understand right these neural electrons
the dimensions are huge it goes into
like thousands or maybe hundreds and
your brain Unfortunately they don't have
that capacity to imagine that way right
so how do you do this
explainable Frameworks uh I can start
with that one is called as shap the
other one is lime and the third one is
gradient base visualization
so the first is called shapely additive
explanations
here you can see an example of an
American Egret right and then you have
an example of a speed boat
now you can clearly see that
the model is focusing on the neck part
of the American egret and similarly for
a speed boat it's clearly at the point
where you have the speedboat that means
the model is trained really well right
so these are some intuitive ways wherein
you can actually identify
to get a little deeper into this what it
does shap framework it takes inputs from
all the layers of the neural network all
the variables from the neural network
and it tries to give you a summary of
what the entire how the entire neural
network is performing
this is what shap does it's not on an
individual layer level but it takes the
entire neural networks sums it and then
gives you a snapshot of how the
performance is by just feeding an image
right what you can do couple of things
is
sometimes you might have a bigger image
and you might have an assumption that if
I give a bigger image with more noise
noise meaning more background it will
work sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't work but in situations like
these you can clearly know that you may
have to crop the exact region that
distinguishes from all the other ah
all the other classes right
now the second one is called lime lime
is local interpretable model agnostic
explanations right so what line does is
it takes the original image ah what it
does is it does a super pixel
segmentation that's a traditional image
processing technique what that does is I
don't have that slide unfortunately I am
sorry about that what it does is it
groups all the colors together
and it creates clusters
so ah once you have these clusters these
individual clusters are fed through like
a logistic regression model and each
individual cluster is you can say you
can take it like a patch right all the
reds are together all the greens are
together all the backgrounds are
together right you take the entire patch
and you feed it to the logistic
regression model and then you get an
output from that
based on that you will know where the
emphasis is this is the other way to
know right in this you can know okay
where the emphasis is one is in the shop
technique the other one is with lime so
it's a trade-off it depends based on
your use case whether you want to use
sharper whether you want to go with
light right
the next is the gradient based learning
here the model is clearly trained on a
car
and then using a heat map you will know
which part of the car is the model
actually focusing on right so
in this
there are certain ah other techniques
but this is a slightly laborious process
what happens is you take the output of
every layer of the neural network and
then you deconvolve back to your
original image to understand what's
happening so you can literally visualize
every single layer and then you will
clearly know what the neural network is
learning um there is a paper ah by this
person named Jason yasinski on
visualizing neural networks ah he
actually visualized ah facial images ah
by just running through the network and
surprisingly the neural network went to
an extent of identifying individual I
right so that way if you visualize it
it's super helpful
for example ah one experience from my
work ah we were actually detecting
um
these ah
fire extinguishers and parking signs
exit boards the images that we were
getting it had like a spotlight like
this and the neural network was actually
getting confused when we actually
visualize certain layers I know it's a
totally laborious process sometimes may
help it may not help
we actually saw that the network was
also learning the lights and then you
had to figure out a way to cut those
down and then clean your data but in
this way what you are doing is when you
are actually cleaning your data you are
more methodical and you're like going
with the proper reason rather than just
taking a shot and trying out right just
hitting every layer but you're just
being one methodical and more clear
announced in your approach this is a
gradient based
the next is visualization tools right
sometimes there are situations where you
have to train a neural network sometimes
you don't have to train a neural network
but how do you know the performance of
the neural network right so what you can
do is you can cut off the final layer
which actually gives you the class name
and you can just take those embeddings
and then you can either do like a PCA or
a test knee what it does is it breaks
down a high dimension to a lower
Dimension keeping only the most useful
information right and that way you can
cluster it out
the other way it is slightly compute
heavy what you can do is
you can iterate and after each iteration
you can take a snapshot and try to
understand whether the embeddings are
being pushed away or not if the
embeddings are not getting pushed away
that means the network is not actually
learning
this such techniques you have to use
when your loss function starts at a
really low value and it just keeps going
lower and lower
to a point where you clearly do not know
what's happening should I just increase
the epox to like 300 or just keep it at
50 what should I do right in these
situations you can clearly know whether
the Clusters are coming or not or
um
like you get insights that way and this
is something that was super helpful as
well but it's computationally heavy
because once you do finish your trading
you need to write your custom code to
generate this with your test data set
see what's happening uh use certain
metrics for the cluster distances and
then go back this is something that's
not available in like traditional open
source Frameworks like Keras or
tensorflow you may have to write it by
yourself
this is what I was talking about how you
can interpret models with visualization
tools
the next is heuristic based learning
right
how many of you have trained and object
detection model
ok ok for those who don't know an object
detection model you take let's say an
image has a car and in the background it
has Lexa trees but when you pass the
image of a car through the model the
model actually gives you a bounding box
of where the car is right now I'm pretty
sure the strategy is not to train from
scratch but you will just take an
off-the-shelf model and then do some
kind of transfer learning on your custom
data
say you want to detect something
extremely specific right you want to
detect like say patches on the road and
of course with an off-the-shelf model
you can't do it right how do you check
whether the model is learning those
patches that's when you can start
training initially
I don't have an image for that I'm sorry
I actually had an image for this I think
it's missing
so basically it had an image of a person
sitting in a car
it's it was about only training ah
training images to detect people sitting
in a car just people sitting in a car
not pedestrian right in these situations
how do you ah
check whether your model is learning you
can take a small sample as first you can
train it for certain epochs then take a
small sample
and forcibly give the model these images
wherein there is a person sitting in a
car and then see whether it's able to
segment or it's able to give the
bounding box if it's giving the bounding
box then I think the model is learning
these newer features like the way they
are sitting the posture and things like
that so this is what I call as heuristic
based learning just take a sample try it
out see what's going on and then take it
forward
then how do you
take this and then ah
have your kpis or go to your business
right
in in the industry
the data sets keep changing
the standards keep changing
but on a business level all they care is
metrics right
now if you say my model is giving 99 the
business is like super happy
but internally sometimes what data you
you use changes right if the data is not
challenging enough
then if you get 99 then it's not really
great but for the business it's okay
but internally if you have like say some
blurry images keep some tough images and
your metrics go low
that's still fine that's not too bad and
also after you hit a certain point where
you have trained your model enough
each person that you go up is itself a
Herculean task and it's like something
that you really have to appreciate
yourself and
part on your back because it's hard
every person increase that you go it's
something new that you have to learn and
that's the reason these metrics have to
be like very well defined and it's not
always 99 means the model is doing
really great right it depends on the
data set and how the business
understands also like if it's on the
research level what kind of metrics you
keep and then decide on how you can take
it forward
applications so
ah this really happened with me in the
healthcare space so I actually worked on
detection of endoscopic images cervical
cancer images oral cancer images
and
skin cancer images as well
okay you have a great model it's working
very well
if a person has an abnormality
how do you make sure you are right
or how do you even tell the doctor that
the model is correct the model says no
it's not cancerous but the doctor is
like no it's cancerous right
how do you explain these things to the
doctor very quickly like it should be
super quick
these situations these model
interpretability techniques help you can
clearly say that hey this is the heat
map I see this is where I think
I could see an abnormality because in
the end it's a pattern recognition right
it's a pattern recognition problem so
you can clearly have a small tool which
can show that hey I think the model is
giving this but it's giving this because
of these reasons right so that he
understands what's going on and doesn't
take it on a ego level that like how can
a model just say something that I've
been practicing for the last 10 years so
yeah and the second thing is training
neural networks um like I was explaining
uh about how you debug
when you debug is when you actually
learn how to train your neural networks
better
and these techniques actually help in
that
so yes any questions for me
thank you so much for the talk
um this is fascinating I'm wondering if
you've ever used any
um interactivity in some of the
visualizations that you've used for
interpretability interpretability any
any interactive what sorry Interactive
visualizations
yes yes I did there is an open source
tool called Keras whiz I had used that
again that's where it gets super
laborious
it's like they just give you a bunch of
images of different layers you have to
go through each to understand what's
really happening and try out few images
not a lot to really see what's happening
like an example I gave when the light
was on the part that was interesting to
me the model started using that as a
signal and stride highlighting that in
its activation function so that's when I
realized I think I should cut it down so
but the problem is the versions are
changing I think now there could be
better tools and that may not work this
was like three four years ago yeah
hi hi you mentioned uh sap and lime yeah
and you also said that is a model
agonistic what does it mean model like
mixty so it doesn't depend on the model
yes yes it doesn't depend on the model
it does depend on the accuracy of the
model
not even the accuracy of the model it's
it creates I mean it uh just sees the
performance of the model of course you
need a model and then it feeds the data
in a certain way to the model sees the
output of that and they have some
equations that they run and then they
spit out and do you have any
recommendation where I should use sap
when I should use lime or anything I can
do that's a trade-off uh so this is
something that even I've been trying out
uh
both are useful sometimes so it's good
to try out both and then if both give
you the same results or kind of helps
you that way
make sure you talk
the the field of expandable AI has also
a lot of
um I would say dissonant voices that
shows that those visualization
techniques can actually be misleading
um there's quite a huge body of research
that shows that often especially
gradient based visualization methods are
unreliable or they highlight things that
you can demonstrate in the end actually
do not matter and so
knowing about the existence of that
how do you decide if you can actually
trust the explanations from these
visualizations especially when you go
back to your Business Leaders as like
you know sometimes it's very suggestive
like you showed it clearly focuses on
the object right but there's a lot of
research that shows that even if it
focuses on the object it actually might
be misleading and it's
it's not as straightforward as it seems
to be so how do you decide you know do
you keep up with the literature to me to
make sure that some of those
visualization techniques are actually
consistent or usually you have to do say
a hundred different examples and see if
the explanation is indeed consistently
related to the to the result so I right
uh I think like one of the example we
had to identify a specific pattern of
course not like an arauco marker but a
specific
pattern in a in a particular item
so what really happened was the model
would not give the right result right if
the model gives the right result it's
like great you will not even take this
path right so since the model didn't
give it that's when I had to take this
part to understand like what is it that
it's actually understanding so it was
like ah it was like some kind of a
pattern that we had to identify and it
had like a yellow background
so it started highlighting the yellow
background more using just simple grad
cam visualization it's right
highlighting yellow more and started
focusing Less on the pattern and that's
when our research moved a little towards
how we can focus more on the pattern and
we try to do like one shot learning
based with giving more like negative
images for a specific and a positive
image for a specific and then trying to
Focus the model more towards the pattern
and not the background so it kind of
gives you these insights to try out and
if that works great in our case it
worked but sometimes it doesn't work too
so that's how it just opens you up to
see how you can solve the problem
a few more minutes for questions so take
your time
um so uh you mentioned that you've been
using uh lime and shap and uh so could
you uh could you talk about uh the cost
considerations of the time that it takes
for slime or shop to generate
explanations and uh how you've what
you've encountered with respect to that
and uh also could you also mentions uh
something about the stability of the
explanations generated using the
gradient based methods have they have
the explanations been stable across
similar inputs and if have there been
occasions where they haven't been stable
okay so uh lime and sharp actually they
are more cleaner Frameworks compared to
the earlier ones the gradient based that
came out and then subsequently when lime
and shaft happened they are more cleaner
and nicer easy to install easy to run
and check it's not too bad gradient
based the problem is there are so many
gradient based techniques that came out
and uh so this visualization part is
something that was helpful to me ah
trying to go through the layers and see
that lime and shaft was more recent back
then it was just grad cam visualization
so I just had to rely on that but
offload like after this I haven't really
gone back to that and made a comparison
I still strongly feel lime and sharper
way better
thank you for the talk
um so since you have some extensive
experience with medical image analysis
too as you mentioned I was wondering
that you know like specifically when we
are trying to convince the clinicians
um the problem is that like if a
particular exam is like let's say
positive like it has cancer image let's
say right so um so so all these heat
Maps based techniques can you know help
us localize the tumor let's say but
specifically for negative exams it is
not trying to localize anything the heat
Maps kind of identify the portions with
high intensity that it used to say that
this particular exam does not have
cancer but that may not be a sufficient
evidence to you know kind of convince
the clinicians to adopt this particular
model into their clinical settings so do
you foresee the development of these
explainable AI techniques may be
specifically in the healthcare industry
to kind of have some more detailed
explanations accompanying you know just
these heat Maps
yes
since I've worked in the retail and a
little bit on the insurance and
Healthcare Healthcare is like extremely
sensitive when you give a certain result
um it's too emotional as well when you
talk to patients or when a doctor says
right you got to be like 100 sure or
maybe even higher when it comes to these
other areas you can use other signals
right let's say in autonomous vehicles
what they do is they have multiple
signals coming like say if you see a
person they'll be like a radar saying
the same thing camera saying the same
thing a point Cloud saying the same
thing and you're like sure but in
healthcare it's just that one thing
right and to give you an example I was
working on endoscopic images wherein the
torch was actually so it's it has like
an inbuilt torch and that actually
highlights the area so that you can
capture better images
most of the times the network would say
it's cancerous
right so that's when to make sure you
are 100 sure on what you say it's better
to give an explanation sometimes you
might be wrong but if you can say to the
doctor that hey I think we are totally
wrong this is the reason why we are
wrong maybe we need more images of this
but this is literally what the model is
telling and that way you can convince it
to him then just saying yes or no
because it can work both ways a false
positive it's like a
slightly not a not a good situation to
be with so this is one of the ways that
you can try
thank you yeah
so when you're embarking on a training
run and you're looking at your learning
curves and assessing your loss and
figuring out a good place to to stop
model training because neural Nets are
computationally expensive to train do
you have any tools or visualization
resources that you would recommend to
assess essentially model training
against something like GPU cost
especially for business stakeholders who
might be wondering about the costs that
get occurred during model training
so um so you are saying that what about
the GPU cost and how do you explain the
GPU cost during training
okay okay so you need to show value
first right and these are certain
techniques that you can use to say that
hey I think I really see a value but I
see a om error happening sorry just
kidding uh I'm I'm seriously seeing an
error here because I see that there's so
much data available with you all that we
can do so much and you can just start
with something small and then
totally nail it completely like as a
prototype and then show it to them and
these techniques thankfully will kind of
they get convinced right and that way
you can tell them and be like okay I
think I may need a higher GPU to give
you a better performance with this it's
hard you can probably go in that route
thank you
okay we're gonna have to wrap it up in
the sake of time but I want to thank
sumed for taking the time and energy to
prepare this presentation so thank you
very much thank you thank you everyone